let's start today talking a little bit
about vaccines
at this relatively later stage in the
pandemic for the united states there's
much still to be done globally but at
this
stage in the u.s where we could be
moving even more quickly
in crushing the virus 41 of republicans
still refuse to get themselves
vaccinated and sadly this number is down
only two percentage points from last
month you might remember last month we
had a new poll
which said 43 percent of republicans are
refusing the covet vaccine that has
declined but only two percentage points
to 41.
this is a new pbs npr
marist poll which finds that only four
percent of democrats
say i don't want the vaccine and yet 41
of republicans say they do not plan to
get vaccinated
and this truly could lead to more
eventual deaths for republicans than for
democrats which would at least to some
degree
shift the electoral balance what i mean
by that is
if mostly republicans are dying once we
get to the point at which everyone who
wants a vaccine has gotten a vaccine
it seems that would be bad for
republicans in their races
and maybe that and that alone at some
point or in some way
will influence republican elected
officials to encourage their voters to
get vaccinated but consider the
absurdity of this situation
the people who all along have been
saying there's really no serious
pandemic here
we don't have to do anything special we
don't have to go out of our way to
behave any differently open everything
right away uh get masks off those
very people who are the ones that never
wanted to wear masks
and don't want to get vaccinated are the
ones that say
open everything well wearing the mask
and get when that was the right thing
before we knew that vaccinated people
no longer need to wear masks per the cdc
getting vaccinated that would help us
open as quickly as possible and yet they
are refusing to do it
now overall 24 of the entire country
does not plan
to get vaccinated which is okay for herd
immunity once kids can get vaccinated
what i mean is if we do vaccinate 76
of all americans by all measures that's
enough to completely crush the curve
and get to a practical herd immunity
there will be sort of like a super
immunity in states where people
almost all want to get vaccinated places
like california
new york massachusetts where there's
more than 90 percent
interest in vaccination they will have
like a super immunity
on the other hand you will have cluster
outbursts
among uh unvaccinated people
in some parts of the country that are
not so big on getting themselves
vaccinated but the issue is no longer
vaccine supply
and that's maybe one of the most
infuriating aspects of this
we have the incredibly fortunate
situation
that many countries are dreaming of
which is vaccines for everyone there are
countries
desperate to get vaccines and start
vaccinating people
we have vaccines all adults are eligible
anyone 12 and over is eligible for the
pfizer vaccine in most states you can
now just walk in
no appointment just go and get a vaccine
and 41 of republicans just don't want it
and it's a very similar situation
with abortion i've used this analogy
before
they say we want zero abortions
great we know uh how to get in that
direction
give everybody contraception at no cost
out of pocket
teach everybody comprehensive sex
education this reduces the number of
unwanted pregnancies
and it reduces the demand for abortions
oh no we don't want to do that that's
crazy
that either violates our conscience or
it violates our religion or it violates
our morality or whatever the case
that's how you reduce abortions though
when they don't want to do it and it's
the exact same thing here hey we want
everything
back to normal cool just wear a mask
for now until the cdc says you don't
have to and as soon as you can get
yourself vaccinated get yourself
vaccinated
oh no not that that we're not going to
do it is fascinating that many of the
same people
who believed in hydroxychloroquine
absent any reason to believe in it as a
treatment for kovid
don't believe actual science like
vaccines the good
news is it's mostly the unvaccinated who
remain at risk now
it's not a hundred percent like that
because
there are some people who can't get
vaccinated because of specific medical
conditions
so you getting vaccinated protects them
there are people remember when we say
the vaccine is 92 to 95
effective that means five to eight
percent of people who get the vaccine
but because of a normal bell curve
distribution never develop
antibodies even though they did go and
get themselves vaccinated so
do the respectful thing do it for your
fellow homo sapiens go and get yourself
vaccinated
not necessarily or not only because
you're
assessing your personal risk but because
you're a member of society
you're a member of the human race and
maybe you would do something
that has somebody else in mind i know
that that's a crazy idea so
the bad news 41 of republicans still
don't want the vaccine
the good news if we are to focus on the
good news is
mostly the risk of people not
vaccinating is to themselves
although there is still risk to others
uh
and that number has gone down a little
bit 43
to 41 it's a little bit better we'll
continue to track vaccination numbers
and maybe have an
update uh maybe tomorrow maybe on
thursday
you really have to see this to believe
it the very
same republican congressman who denied
that there was any insurrection on
january 6
has now been caught in pictures showing
him looking
panicked and barricading the doors of
the house of representatives with
furniture to try to stop the
insurrectionists who he claimed don't
exist
from coming into the house of
representatives i'm speaking about
republican congressman andrew clyde
just last week he said the riot looked
like a quote
normal tourist visit those are comments
for which he was rightly excoriated
ridiculous comments here is a picture
of the same andrew clyde who said
insurrection
no this is just a tour here he is
pushing a piece of furniture
surrounded by security guards up against
the doors of the house of
representatives
that's a normal tourist visit normal
tourist visits require
members of the house of representatives
to barricade the doors with furniture
here's another picture of clyde and he
looks i mean to say he looks scared for
his life
is not an exaggeration it doesn't look
like a normal congressional tourist
visit to me
this was clyde's original comment you
really have to see it to believe it
let me be clear there was no
insurrection and to call it an
insurrection in my opinion
is a bold-faced lie watching the tv
footage of those who entered the capital
and walked through statuary hall showed
people in an orderly fashion staying
between the stanchions and ropes taking
videos and pictures
you know if you didn't know the tv
footage was a video from january the 6th
you would actually think it was a normal
tourist visit it was a
normal tourist visit and yet
congressman andrew clyde holding
up furniture against the door
to prevent the insurrectionists from
breaking in
i haven't heard a response from clyde
yet
to these pictures being uncovered but
what could he possibly
say oh he was trying to pull down the
furniture
to let the peaceful visitors in the
image is deceptive
because he was taking down the
barricades not
uh putting them up i can't even imagine
what kind of response there would be
here but that's one of the most absurd
that i can think of
another possibility would be like maybe
to argue semantics
yes they were breaking in yes some of
them were being violent yes they were
trespassing but
we can't call it an insurrection because
they didn't really have a plan for how
they would govern if they succeeded in
overthrowing the government and stopping
the process
of counting the electoral votes like in
some literal semantic sense because they
didn't have a plan
for taking over control of the
government it's not an insurrection i
don't know
but bottom line this is yet another
attempt to normalize the situation
and what this goes to is that if they
can make us think
if they can make us believe that what
took place was normal
and just blown out of proportion maybe
by the left maybe they were
not even real trumpists as they love to
say then
they and their fellow republicans might
be off the hook
for any wrongdoing in pushing for that
january 16th direction by spending
months claiming the election was stolen
and that of course includes donald trump
as well
in normal circumstances by which i mean
sometime in the past not recently
we might have thrown these people out of
government by now but republican
victimhood
has allowed them to cry foul to blame
everybody else
and to continue to
wreak havoc and do damage in their
senate and house of representative jobs
and roles and case in point
yesterday's story about marjorie taylor
greene and her
long record of harassment of fellow
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
that type of behavior would get almost
anyone
fired from their job if you treated a
co-worker in that way
if in my organization i found out
that somebody did what marjorie taylor
green
has done to alexandria ocasio-cortez i
would have to meet with them and i would
have to say
you can't work here anymore this is it
it's that's not how this works
it's not allowable we can't have that
it's outrageous
but they have to some degree
successfully normalized all of this
stuff
and uh that has also included obvious
lying obvious lying has been completely
normalized as well so you know if i
could wrap up with something
optimistic or or forward-looking that is
anything other than
um uh just horrible desperation
for some kind of semblance of normality
i would
but i don't see any appetite from the
american right wing from the republican
party
from particularly this trumpian wing of
the republican party
to hold any of these people accountable
and so the fear
is and i think that the last few months
have shown us that it's a well-founded
fear
the fear is they will continue to do
this stuff and attempt to rewrite
history
normalize absolutely horrendous things
um
well into the 2022 election and if
donald trump gets his way and he gets to
decide
who is on the approved list of good good
boys and bad boys good girls and bad
girls and and who wins in 2022
not only may republicans take over the
house it may be
a particularly trumpian republican um
wing that takes over the house and it
sets the stage for trump or maybe if you
can imagine
someone even worse in 2024 so i don't
think this is trivial stuff
and i know we started with just the
kernel which is a guy who was
barricading the doors now claims there
really wasn't an insurrection
and it is a form of gaslighting that
leads to a lot of potentially horrible
things getting into the midterms in the
2024 election so we will continue to
follow it
and um there are others like
clyde making similarly outrageous
statements which maybe we'll talk about
later this week
remember that monday memorial day we are
doing a one-day membership special if
you've been thinking i don't know maybe
i'll get one of those memberships
get a membership before they run out
on monday memorial day we'll be doing a
big one day discount
you can get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and monday memorial day you'll get an
email telling you how to sign up
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
let us not forget that this program is
an independent media program we have no
corporate backing we have no big uh
corporations or rich dudes or
gals fueling our program and as a result
we depend mostly on individual
subscriptions from people just like you
uh i've met many of them they really are
just like you
in all of the best ways and you can sign
up at joinpakman.com
you will get access to the daily bonus
show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show and
if you would like a discount
you can use the code better21 to save
hugely
off of the cost of a membership there is
a new report
from axios reporter jonathan swann
which tells the story of a donald trump
temper tantrum
in which after losing the 2020 election
trump tried to just pull
troops from around the world now you
might think
that's great i want to bring our troops
home we shouldn't have troops all over
the world the way that we do
and i would agree with you but this was
not a foreign policy calculation by
donald trump
this was not a well-crafted decision to
reduce the military presence around the
world
this was not uh a a calculated
and uh much discussed strategy
for reducing the spread of the american
military throughout the globe
this was a temper tantrum over losing
the election on november 9th of 2020 you
might remember that's the day after the
media finally said okay joe biden won
john mcentee one of donald trump's
favorite aides
gave a note to army colonel colonel
douglas mcgregor
and on that note it said this is what
the president wants you to do
get us out of afghanistan get us out of
iraq and syria
withdraw completely from germany and get
us completely out of africa and mcgregor
explained
you know we can't really just do this by
january 20th
and i certainly just can't do it by
myself and mcentee
said to mcgregor well do what you can
and mcgregor said i really can't do
anything i need like a real order from
the president
i can't just go and pull all of our
troops from around the world
two days later and this is all based on
jonathan swan's axios reporting such a
letter was delivered to the acting
secretary of defense christopher miller
all u.s military forces are to be
withdrawn from somalia by december 31st
all u.s forces are to be withdrawn from
afghanistan by january 15th with
similar unrealistic dates and miller
wondered what the hell is going on here
the department of defense called the
white house lawyer pat chipoloni
and asked what is going on here they
called trump's national security adviser
robert o'brien
no one had any idea what was going on
this wasn't a plan
this wasn't policy this was just a very
strange temper tantrum
and as jonathan swann writes for axios
the u.s government's top national
security leaders
soon realized they were dealing with an
off the books operation
by trump himself ultimately it didn't
happen
but as you can see this is not the
action of a president who wanted to do
these things
because they were the right things to do
if they were he wouldn't have waited
until november 9th
of the last year of his first term to do
it it was a triggered
tilted man furious that he lost
seemingly wanting to create as much
chaos as possible for joe biden who
would be replacing him just two months
later
and as jonathan swann writes quote
christopher miller told associates he
had three goals
for the finer final weeks of the trump
administration number one no major war
number two no military coup and number
three no troops fighting uh citizens on
the streets of the united states
think about the insanity of the
situation
when the acting national security
adviser acting secretary of defense
says my goals for the lame duck period
are preventing trump from starting a war
preventing trump from using the military
for a coup
and preventing trump from deploying
troops to fight citizens on the streets
of the united states
the more we read stories like this one
the more we realize
just how insanely close we came to an
even greater level of chaos the stuff
that was apparently narrowly avoided
almost makes the january sixth
insurrection look
relatively mild in comparison and
between the riots
and trump trying to overturn the
election results and stay in power
and on a whim saying pull all troops
from everywhere
and having lawyers in and talking about
martial law
uh or seizing voting machines or
whatever else
the stuff that happened is bad enough
but look at all of the things we're
learning about that almost happened and
as i've said when donald trump left
it was way worse than we knew over time
we're going to learn
more but i don't know that we'll ever
really learn
the full scope of exactly how bad it was
and this is just yet another thing and
it i know that
you know there are probably going to be
people in my audience i've already seen
it in other enclaves there's probably
some people in my audience
who maybe identify with what is
sometimes called the revolutionary left
who will say this was trump outflanking
the left
on the spread of the american military
trump was trying to pull troops from all
these places that troops arguably
shouldn't even be in
and now leftists like david pakman uh
are
saying that it was a bad idea i'm not
saying it was a bad idea and i've been
arguing for drawing down troops in
germany and in many other places for a
decade on this program
the point is this wasn't policy this was
the day after the election was called
for biden
trump without consulting with anyone and
for no strategic reason for no well
thought out
foreign policy reason just says i'm
going to create an
s storm for lack of a better term for
joe biden
and just start pulling troops
haphazardly it is not policy
and this is not how anybody who is a
thinking individual would say
it should be done we should be drawing
down troops we should be reducing our
military footprint there's no question
about it
but if you do it as policy you don't do
it once you're already a lame duck that
doesn't make any sense and that's
pathetic
we had every reason to believe that very
soon
matt gates and his crime story
would be back in the news and it has
just exploded back
into the news as gates associate joel
greenberg has now pleaded guilty
to six federal crimes including sex
trafficking of 18. exactly
the same crime that matt gates is being
investigated for now as a reminder
joel greenberg is a former tax collector
in florida seminole county
when we learned that this joel greenberg
decided to cooperate with investigators
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller held a
hilarious press briefing
outside a courthouse and was straight up
asked did your client joel greenberg
introduce matt gates to underage girls
and check out
the then hilarious response from
greenberg's lawyer
did your client introduce nat gates to
any underage girls
or secularly
all right so i'm just going to let you
sit down there
and so i can look over your head and
ignore that question
i apologize i i just can't answer that
question i wasn't okay
that was that was a little devious you
hiding down there below and
you zing that at me you know so
yeah well it's looking very very bad
again six guilty pleas for joel
greenberg
sex trafficking a minor id theft
stalking and fraud
and again remember we learned a couple
of weeks ago about a letter
sent by joel greenberg to roger stone
admitting that he introduced matt gates
to young girls
the six charges that greenberg has pled
guilty to
that's down from 33 charges we can only
imagine
it's six instead of 33 because of his
cooperation
which should be very scary for
congressman matt gates now on the sex
trafficking of a minor charge
the specific admission is that greenberg
admits to recruiting women
for commercial sex acts and paying them
more than 70 thousand dollars between
2016 and 2018.
this is quickly getting very ugly for
matt gates and the only question now is
if and when gates will get indicted some
people called into the show last week
and said david of course gates is
getting indicted
i'm not sure and we'll get back to that
gates
has of course denied all wrongdoing
and on the friday show this week i'm
going to talk a little bit about
do sexual assault allegations matter
anymore in politics
do they matter to democrats but not to
republicans
or do they not matter at all at this
point in time we're going to talk about
that
friday maybe in this case republicans
should go
sort of with the trump riots defense
remember how trump has said
you know it wasn't real trumpists
writing on january 6th that was like
antifa in disguise or something maybe
they go with
matt gates is really antifa in disguise
matt gates isn't really a republican i
don't know
um it's important to remember though
that if you were joel greenberg
you do not plead guilty even to the six
charges never mind 33
unless you really uh
are are had dead to rights by
investigators
you are setting yourself up at least
potentially for some serious prison time
by pleading guilty you do not plead
guilty to sex trafficking of a minor
unless you have figured out a way to get
leniency by informing about others
or something now in all seriousness are
we going to get accountability
because for the last several weeks gates
almost seems emboldened by this
investigation
he's been running around doing these
america first
tour events promoting all sorts of
election lies writing off this entire
investigation
as some kind of partisan witch hunt
which he conveniently fails to mention
that the investigation started under
donald trump donald trump's
justice department started looking at
gates but was stonewalled
by political appointees to the justice
department
who were political appointees of donald
trump so it's a story with
so much of what's wrong right now
two-tier justice system
cronyism belligerent arrogance hypocrisy
double standards it's everything let's
now see if there is accountability
uh i hope that there is last week or the
week before i said
i don't know if gates is going to end up
indicted i got a few calls and even
played a voicemail from one caller who
said
david i don't know if you're just trying
to be balanced but of course matt gates
is getting indicted
i'm not so sure i'm not so sure uh
let's see if there is accountability it
seems as though the leash
is starting to tighten and we're going
to continue following it
we will have more coverage of the matt
gates fiasco
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show if you want to see
video
of my garden if you want to break from
politics
check out my really intense lettuce
yes l-e-t-t-u-c-e uh on my instagram
david.pakman find me there quick break
back after this
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them today i'm going to be
speaking with kyle reese mandel who's a
senior university lecturer in the
department of history
at the new jersey institute of
technology also
author of the book neighborhood of fear
the suburban crisis in american culture
1975 to 2001. uh it's great to have you
on today kyle
thanks so much for having me david so
the the suburbs as a concept
were maybe more relevant or discussed in
the 2020 presidential election than
than for a long time and we heard from
donald trump the suburban women
should love me and we heard all of these
different proclamations about
um rules and regulations regarding
the study of racial inequality in
suburbs rules and guidance that donald
trump wanted cancelled but joe biden
i guess wanted to keep although i didn't
hear joe biden speak too much about it
one way or the other
can you talk a little bit about the
modern suburb
not from the architectural standpoint of
the subdivision but
as the sort of cultural thing of people
who sometimes
make a higher salary in a city but live
outside of it how long has that dynamic
existed in the united states
so it's pretty familiar in some ways i
think to a lot of people from
you know growing up with television
right that and this is exactly where my
cat will be interested in this
conversation
we love cats it's the second i started
talking
while i was sitting quietly she was just
enjoying the sun
so it's that it's that sort of um sitcom
suburb kind of idea the the nuclear
family the sort of strict gender roles
um everyone's happy everyone's safe uh
and so that cultural ideal emerges after
world war ii with this
you know the invention of the modern
suburbs so suburbs existed before that
but they were not
sort of necessarily the same kind of
formation so
and this is sort of average in american
history this idea of the single-family
house the nuclear family
and this arrangement of gender roles um
and sort of culture around
neighboring upward mobility home
ownership these are all new things
uh after world war ii the um
i mean correct me if i'm wrong but it
seems as though the culture of sort of
fear
in the suburbs about burglars kidnappers
home invasions people coming from the
city
targeting people in suburbs is there
something around the 70s that made that
start to grow as as an idea that people
talked about
yes so there's there's a few things that
happen so one is
to your previous question is that the
suburbs are kind of founded on this idea
of safety
and family and so people who move there
in this sort of later period by the
1970s right
they're expecting that kind of culture
that kind of environment that kind of
safety
and what they find by the mid 70s that's
actually more dangerous than they
imagined and so in the ways you were
just pointing out
sort of criminally morally
environmentally and to some degree the
fear is not necessarily external right
it's not that it is people from the city
coming to your suburb to rob you but
it's that people are lurking in your own
neighborhood who
are almost invisible right they are not
this kind of necessarily racialized
other right but they are people who can
move freely and break into your home in
the middle of the day steal your child
from the mall
do these kinds of things so it's
actually a moment where they start to
feel this
this fear or threat internally rather
than externally right because the
earlier period as you probably know is
defined by sort of racial exclusion
right um and fears of racial integration
and those fears don't go away in that
you know after sort of 1975 but it
includes now these internal threats
within within cities the concept of
redlining
is maybe known to many in the audience
as a way to sort of uh
dictate racial lines between
neighborhoods
can you talk a little bit about from the
from the origins of suburbs
how were they racialized what were the
ways in which they were made
sort of race-based neighborhoods in a
sense
yeah so as you're probably aware uh
racial segregation
uh through space is not invented in you
know 1945 right that this exists
consistently throughout american history
right obviously during the period of
slavery but even after and jim crow etc
that
you know separating people by race and
space is not new
right what i really love is she manages
to go under the camera so i look insane
uh but but so the policy of redlining
comes out the 1930s and the federal
housing authority
during the great depression as a way to
help homeowners particularly farm owners
not just homeowners there weren't that
many homeowners
but one of the key ways in which they
evaluate investment right so the
government's giving out billions of
dollars
basically to rescue people is they say
we must consider the character of the
neighborhood including
who lives there by race and so this
bakes into the rules of housing
considerations of race and space and
value so when we have the suburban boom
of the 1940s and 50s
banks real estate agents homeowners are
all seeing property through the lens of
race that if black people live in my
neighborhood it'll be worth less
i won't be able to sell my home et
cetera et cetera and and of course the
inverse is true that
black people that have extreme
difficulty buying homes because they
can't get loans
they won't be allowed into these
neighborhoods so this is sort of the
legacy of redlining
what um i mean it seems intuitively that
if you have people earning city salaries
and buying homes in the suburbs that
that is that is quite literally a
transfer of wealth from one
sort of uh uh structure to another
but there's probably more to that
transfer when it comes to
maybe political power or or sort of in
other ways can you talk about some of
those other things
yeah so the outcomes of redlining and
suburbanization right so they're
happening at the same time
for the same reason so you end up with
urban crisis which is this moment of
a profound disinvestment in cities in
the 1960s it leads to the urban
rebellions you probably know about watts
or newark etc
so by the 70s the mass exodus of
generally speaking white people but
upwardly mobile white people
means that political power is following
them right representation in congress
particularly representation in state
legislatures and frankly
it's as we know now right it's a lot
easier to vote as a suburban white
person than an urban person of color
so they are overrepresented in some
sense politically so
that movement of people really is
dragging with them this kind of base of
voting power at sort of every level of
government
when uh when ronald reagan was president
it seems as though
that was great for the suburbs but i'd
be interested in
in hearing a little bit about was it
ideological
and some of the stories that reagan told
or was there any actual
policy shift so both um
again the sort of backlash against the
welfare state ultimately right
cities more than suburbs so by the time
he becomes president
his policy of sort of localism
privatization
um less government etc really empowers
people who are already powerful
right government already helps them they
don't need a lot more help versus say
people who need expanded welfare
benefits or snap or something else
so this retrenchment of government and
spending money on social welfare
you know healthcare etc um allows
suburbanites to be empowered because
they already have all the advantages in
the system already structured to benefit
them
so they don't necessarily and in fact
they vote against those kinds of things
right the tax revolts of the 1970s are
exactly about that that
we don't want our tax money going into
these urban places we want to stay in
our neighborhoods we want our money back
right i i'm kind i want to talk a little
bit about
the the um power differences between
just like small towns versus suburbs but
maybe first it would be useful to talk a
little bit about
when we talk about a suburb i mean i
think the idea is
it's part of a metro area connected to a
city
it may have a downtown but oftentimes
it's not it's maybe more
residential and and maybe not at all
industrial like
these are just kind of intuitions but
how are we really defining what a suburb
is versus what might just be a small
town
i mean you put your finger on what is a
lot of the historical work right he's
trying to figure out what are we
actually talking about here
we say suburban culture suburban life
suburban place and so
part of the argument making the book and
i think part of the way i teach this to
my students is
it is a construction right it is an idea
as much as anything else so it changes
over time what it means in 1955 is not
the same as 1975 or 1995.
so to your point people imagine
themselves as suburban
right and have um sort of enacting
certain values conducting themselves a
certain way around
law and order politics etc really is
what makes them suburban so
space matters and maybe relationship to
a city matters to some degree but it
doesn't
essentially define a suburb in a way
that i think is ultimately consistent or
allows us to say
this is absolutely a suburb this is
absolutely not so you could have a small
town and describe it as
suburban without it necessarily being a
suburb
because of is it a combination of
ideology
economics yeah exactly its culture
its values and it is space right that
you know the suburban sprawl of the
1970s the continuous or
development of land means that the
further and further you go out the less
relationship any place is really going
to have to an urban center so
you know the urban center is the center
of economic life the urban center as
sort of commuting or shopping right all
these things go away by the 1970s and
80s for most people
and especially as you move further
further out places like california or
pennsylvania
places that have a lot of farmland to
get developed so what
what can we say would be some of the
things that distinguish a
suburb from just like a relatively
wealthy smaller
small city or large town so i would
argue that i would
i probably always ask the question of
like when and where are we talking about
but i think
you know the consistent things
particularly in post-war america are
right
single-family housing focus on the
nuclear family or this idea of the
nuclear family around these particular
gender roles
and i think a culture of privatization
and local control that
the idea that i live here for these
reasons i control the space the school
board the mayor
um and this is in some way an economic
investment in my future by owning a home
that those things are pretty consistent
as what i would consider suburban values
but how they play out is really again
kind of depends on when we're talking
about this is part of the argument the
book is
by the late 70s people are starting to
define themselves in relation to their
fears
that instead of saying this is what i
own and what i have when i feel safe i
am now afraid of
these number of things and i'm going to
react to them in certain ways that's
interesting so so
to put some examples to it a kind of a
wealthier college town in north carolina
or western massachusetts those those
might be suburban at least in their sort
of feel and idea
but maybe like a poor midwestern
small city or large town with tons of
public housing
would not be suburban under this general
idea
yeah and i mean again intentionally so
and this
sort of gets back to you to redlining
and ultimately urban renewal policies
after world war ii which is
suburbs many many places outside cities
pass laws forbidding public housing
itself right
we will not even allow it to be built
here so uh and public housing really
stops being built by the 1970s we moved
to this sort of voucher system and other
things
but we're even having this conversation
today and back to your you know sort of
original point about donald trump
part of what he was saying about fair
housing open house and equal housing
right is that he was trying to scare
some urbanites that they will build
apartment buildings
right to facilitate you know more dense
housing right yeah
he's sort of saying undermines the idea
of your neighborhood um
the culture of the place yeah so let's
talk i mean when trump was talking about
the suburbs will
be over under joe biden and all this it
seemed
to me that there was a racialized aspect
of the idea
of dangerous brown people coming into a
place that's currently mostly white
is that a crazy way to interpret what he
was getting at
no and i think the thing about uh trump
is that he's stuck in a particular
vision of america
already right that of the 50s 60s maybe
even the 1970s
that that was that moment right that was
very truly
the subject truly defined by these very
strict boundaries around race and class
to the point where you have white
citizens councils you know policing
streets to keep out
black people from moving through not
just moving in but his vision
is old politically and sort of i think
just um
in any material sense the suburb he's
trying to defend is already gone
that suburban suburban residents and
voters largely hold these progressive
values even if they don't enact them so
they're never going to come out and say
we don't want blank right they're going
to say we want to protect
this neighborhood the culture of this
place right the character of the
neighborhood
and that allows them to do all sorts of
things right not just keep out perhaps
people they see lower class or
racialized to others but also
environmental things they see as
dangerous etc
so it gives them a lot of power to not
play the race card to think about it in
racial terms
and in fact i think they endorse in many
ways sort of progressive or
values around diversity so are
i guess the question would be are
suburbs
actually progressive or do they endorse
a language of progressivism
and they could really range politically
yeah this is the lesson of the 1980s is
that
and to some degree the reaction to civil
rights is that white people learn to use
the language of civil rights to make
claims
and this includes suburbanites and they
learn how to talk about race and class
without talking about race and class
they're the euphemisms of all these
things
the famous lee atwater quote the the
strategist for for ronald reagan
and george h.w bush that you know you
can't go around screaming the n-word
anymore you have to say you know
it's about school integration or
whatever it might be um
so to some degree i would say yes you're
right that what suburbanites care about
is an ideology of local power
that what serves that interest they will
embrace so they might vote for joe biden
or barack obama or even bill clinton
right
but they don't necessarily want them to
enact those changes in their
neighborhood
yeah even though they still embrace that
idea of sort of uh
what i think we consider progressive
values one of the um phrases or or
claims that's been thrown around a lot
recently is that more and more
uh people are going back to living in
cities
and and in urban environments the it
seems that there would be
some kind of seesaw effect suburb rural
and city and if more people are heading
to cities that would cause a change not
only in the cities but also in the
suburbs but
is is that the case what are the changes
we're seeing as a result of that
yeah i think the generation the second
or third generation of people raised in
suburbs returned to the city as quote
unquote fun city the place to go
that is gentrified that is safe um some
scholars make the argument that this is
the suburbanization of the city itself
right
we sort of erase or marginalize the
people who've been in these
neighborhoods for many years you know
mostly
um latinx or black we make it safe we
bring these amenities these restaurants
these bars we sort of idealize this past
this sort of industrial past and our
culture
but really it's about bringing in this
kind of investment right the kind of
tourism dollars consumer dollars
rental dollars that didn't exist there
before um as a reaction to the bland
staleness of the suburbs right like you
know all the things that people are
saying in the 1980s particularly in
hardcore punk of
you know this is just boring and
horrible and terrible it's about tv and
fast food
uh whereas this authentic urban
experience exists that i can access
big picture just to kind of uh uh wrap
the conversation
in thinking about the next you know 10
20 years um
what what do you see as sort of the
shifts in terms of
rural suburban and urban that
seem to be guided by the interests of
the people that are now becoming
homeowners will the shift to
urbanization continue or do you expect
it to change or reverse
well one is there are fewer homeowners
right so probably
i suspect you're around my age or
younger our generation are not going to
be the generation of homeowners in the
same way because we're not being
facilitated by the market or the
government to own homes so we may
inherit homes many of us right because
we're
you know some largely white people will
get our parents or grandparents homes
but home ownership i think as an idea
might have to be really reconfigured
because people are desiring some some
intermediary between urban and suburban
experiences convenience
locality um but also some sort of uh
idea of authenticity
but the pandemic also really throws us
into high relief right we've seen
i i think the exodus is maybe uh
overemphasized but people have moved
out of the city seeing it as sort of the
home of pestilence right
you know this kind of almost 19th
century idea of the city so
it's hard to say and think about public
health or other things what that might
really mean
we may really see people kind of move
far out and go quote-unquote back to the
land like a lot of people did in the
1970s
yeah that's uh that's a question which i
think as you point out we just don't
don't really know yet it's a new it's a
new question uh we've been speaking with
kyle
reese mandel who's a senior university
lecturer in history
at the new jersey institute of
technology the book is neighborhood of
fear the suburban crisis in american
culture
1975-2001 kyle so great having you on i
really appreciate it
thanks for me i really enjoyed it
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does all day very very concerning to a
lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account at david pakman
show
so in all likelihood donald trump is not
nearly as rich
as he claims to be we know that donald
trump inflates the value of his real
estate when it's for the purposes of
claiming a higher net worth
or when it's for the purposes of
securing a loan but minimizes the value
of his real estate when it's
uh an effort to avoid taxation but this
story is just kind of weird
because presumably donald trump is a
billionaire
the question is to what degree is he a
billionaire and yet in the last few
months donald trump has taken
65 000 in optional federal pension
payments
for former presidents since he left
office in january
and you might recall that during his
presidency trump made a very big deal
out of donating his presidential salary
back to different federal agencies maybe
some charities maybe it was just
agencies and he doesn't need the money
and all of that different stuff and yet
billionaire donald trump is now taking
65 000 from the presidential
pension fund now you might remember
the congressional uh the not the
congressional
the constitution requires that
presidents take a salary while in office
they can donate it back fine but there's
nothing constitutionally that says an
ex-president must
take their pension now this is of course
completely within trump's rights to do
but i find it strange to some degree
because if you look at a more realistic
estimate of donald trump's net worth
it's 2.3 billion dollars relative to 2.3
billion dollars
65 000 is .0028 percent of his net worth
so to think about it in in terms that
might be more
uh applicable to the average person this
is equivalent to someone with the median
american net worth which is 121 thousand
dollars
going through a process to dollars
request
forty cents think about that for a
second if you retire from a job or you
get laid off or whatever
and someone comes to you and they say
sir if you want
you can request a pension you go through
this process
and will give you three dollars and
forty cents
would most people go through that
trouble if their net worth is a hundred
and twenty one thousand dollars
that's what donald trump is doing here
so what's going on i mean it reminds me
of you know
but people who who go to the bank to
cash a check for 12 cents
the upside is by taking this
he seems to recognize he's no longer the
president because this is a federal
pension for
ex-presidents so maybe that's sort of
like an upside here
and being a former president comes with
many perks there's lifetime secret
service protection
uh there's travel reimbursements there's
medical insurance there's a budget for
an office and staff and
the presidential library maybe they have
to fundraise for the presidential
library now i don't that i don't
remember
uh but the point is in terms of the fen
the pension
it's not mandatory so is trump just
so greedy and so cheap
that he won't turn anything down and
he'll go through the process of getting
something that is the equivalent at his
net worth
of three dollars and forty cents for a
person of average or median net worth
maybe he needs the money because a lot
of that net worth
is completely illiquid is he desperate
i don't know we've talked about those
controversial loans
that we knew would start to come due
during what would have been his second
term and thankfully
is not because he lost maybe that's
related but i find that there's
something
sort of strange about it and maybe it's
a simple i mean let me know what you
think
maybe it really is as simple as donald
trump
uh just can't turn any money down
because of his personality and because
of who he is
um maybe there's some other explanation
i don't know but
billionaire multi-billionaire donald
trump
going through the process of requesting
filing for and obtaining what is
for his level of net worth equivalent to
three dollars worth
of a federal presidential pension for
ex-presidents
am i the only one finding something
weird about that let me know
this is really funny as many of you know
or maybe you don't and i'll tell you joe
biden is sort of doing
pretty okay as president there's no
perfect president ever president every
president
does lots of things that people don't
agree with that i don't agree with okay
but in this hyper-polarized enviro
environment that we have in the united
states
joe biden's approval is quite healthy
it's much higher than donald trump's
ever was
and joe biden already in these first few
months of his presidency has some
important
major achievements including the covet
relief bill including
an incredibly successful vaccine rollout
and some other things
with much more planned fox news and
other
right-wing media are completely out of
ideas about what to cover
they tried fake scandals they tried
ginning up a crisis at the border which
sort of worked actually
they tried attacking the relationship
between joe and jill biden as fake and
stage managed for public perception
and none of it is really sticking i mean
the border thing is sticking a little
bit
but a lot of this stuff is just not
sticking and
look at the pathetic things that they
tried last night alone
here is tucker carlson claiming that joe
biden's
secretary of defense lloyd austin said
that the single greatest risk our
soldiers face
is having to serve alongside trump
supporters but when you watch the clip
of lloyd austin that he plays
lloyd austin doesn't actually say that
it is a fake
scandal take a look existential
if you've got a cliche he will read it
on television that was lloyd austin of
course
lloyd austin is a former defense
contractor not surprisingly he's a
full-time audiolog as well
having lloyd austin at the pentagon is
like handing control of the entire us
military to the editorial page of the
new york times
here is lloyd austin explaining the
single scariest risk our soldiers face
is the possibility they might have to
serve alongside americans who didn't
vote for joe biden
and if confirmed i will fight hard to
stamp out sexual assault
and to rid our ranks of racist and
extremists
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
he's a joke and a mediocrity and of
course he was confirmed
by the senate as if he was impressive
but he's not so understand that
tucker says lloyd austin claimed
the biggest risk to our troops is
serving alongside people who didn't vote
for joe biden
he plays a clip and in the clip lloyd
austin says we've got to get sexual
assault out of the military
we've got to get racists out of the
military and we've got to get extremists
out of the military now maybe tucker
carlson
knows that the racists and the
extremists and the sexual assaulters or
trump supporters i don't know i'm not
saying that
but uh linguistically i can't see any
other connection between what
tucker carlson said is in that clip and
what lloyd
austin actually says then tucker carlson
uses the latest bill gates jeffrey
epstein revelations
to just wide openly pander to the q
anon people take a look at this so just
days after bill gates told us
on twitter that he was getting a divorce
there was new information
about his relationship with jeffrey
epstein
you know those conspiracy theorists say
a small group of really powerful people
control the world and have an interest
in
little kids just a conspiracy theory but
we will tell you what we do know
that's just a head edgy stuff right so
just straight up pandering to cue and on
there
maybe this helps his ratings maybe he
has a big q anon
contingent in his audience i don't
really know then sean hannity
brings in donald trump jr for a segment
on the steele
dossier from
was it 2016 2017 we're almost halfway
through 2021
and hannity brings on the son of a
former president
to talk about a five-year-old document a
fox host
laura ingraham going with a narrative
about the democratic party being in
chaos and falling apart and being in
disarray
she had one headline called things are
clearly falling apart for democrats
and then another which included
right-wing bomb thrower
dinesh d'azuza as a guest
which was called quote gop views
gain traction as dems in disarray
and of course this is all completely
fake
it's all completely made up if the
current administration is notable for
anything
it's that we are four months in and
there are just no
scandals and things are calm and
uncontroversial now we can all say
well joe biden didn't handle stopping
the deportations the way that he
promised and i would be right there with
you
and joe biden hasn't done enough here or
he hasn't done enough there or i don't
like
the deadline he set for when to get
troops out of afghanistan he said it at
september 11th he should have done it by
may 1st like donald trump
these are all fair criticisms and things
that we can all talk about but
there's really no disarray there's
really no scandal there's really no
chaos we're four months in
uh joe biden has gotten some major
things done most americans are more or
less happy with it and americans are
very happy with the coveted stimulus
bill that was done
americans are very happy with joe
biden's handling of the pandemic
and americans are very happy with joe
biden's handling of the vaccine rollout
lastly from laura ingram another
blockbuster powerful story called quote
the left doesn't actually have
an agenda and this one is particularly
funny
because joe biden passed covid stimulus
rolled out vaccines has a jobs bill
proposal
has an infrastructure bill proposal has
made some tweaks to gun safety doesn't
mean you have to like them or think
they're enough but he made some tweaks
to gun safety
and yet it is republicans who for four
years
and especially now openly so mitch
mcconnell said it
they are not about anything other than
stop
democrats from doing anything under
barack obama
the republican agenda was stop obama
from doing anything
under trump the agenda was undo anything
we can that barack obama did
and under joe biden the agenda is not
really an agenda
it's prevent joe biden from doing
anything it's a good critique not having
an agenda not being for anything if it
were true
it happens to be true of the republican
party and
i don't know if they can do this for the
next four years like at some point
will they have to come up with something
more substantive to slam joe biden about
at some point i mean most presidents
have some scandals
obama was sort of out of the ordinary in
the sense that he didn't have any major
scandal
will they come up with something
substantive or will they will something
happen that is actually
a fair critique of joe biden that would
fall under the umbrella of scandal or
disarray
let me know what you think but they seem
committed
to trying to stop joe biden from doing
anything
and from claiming that joe biden is
getting nothing done and is embroiled in
scandal when that's actually not the
case that's going on
let me know what you think can they do
this for four years without anything
substantive
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
in the wake of the matt gates
allegations of
possible statutory rape and child sex
trafficking and so on and so forth
we had a great caller with advice this
is important advice this is important
advice for anybody in the audience if
you want to avoid being charged with
statutory rape
okay and i think most people would want
to avoid being charged with that
here is a caller explaining to you how
to do it take a listen
all right this is jane from pennsylvania
right there is one sure way for a man to
avoid
being charged with statutory rape if you
don't know her well enough to know
her correct age don't have sex with her
wow what a vote
uh i don't know why i love that caller i
think it's the delivery
and the accent and it's just absolutely
perfect
yeah that's good advice and now you know
there will be
you hear about these stories where um
one one the accused will say they lied
about their age
they just lied and you know the
difference if
i'm if i'm 30 the difference between a
17
and an 18 year old is not obvious
and what am i going to do check for id
or something like that so you'll you'll
hear
those stories but generally speaking
this is good advice
and um i mean in most cases wouldn't you
be able to you know if you're
i i i don't even want to speculate but
the point is
you would learn the truth of someone's
life and like
if they're going to high school rather
than college or whatever
you would think that these cases of i
was really
tricked by someone claiming to be of a
certain age those
seem like they would be relatively rare
and i think that the advice there from
jane is is quite good
we've got a great bonus show coming up
for you today
we will talk about pro-tax billionaires
who are protesting
not in front of jeff bezos's house but
in front of jeff bezos's
many homes okay that's a protest that
pro-tax millionaires are undertaking
number two the supreme court is
restricting police authority to enter
homes without a warrant
and we will talk about the circumstances
and number three
a new study from the world health
organization finds that
overwork has killed more than 745 000
people in a year
this is why we do our six-month
vacations that we are so
uh well known for um you know this is a
real issue and it's more an issue in
some countries than in others
and we're going to talk about the
cultural aspect of it we're going to
talk about the physiological aspect of
it but uh
three-quarters of a million people in a
year
believed to have died from what is being
described as
over work uh and we will talk about
all of those stories and much more when
i am joined by producer pat
on today's bonus show we may even give
uh
some awards out to the bonus show today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show patreon.com david
padman show i'll see you on the bonus
show